очевидно ми не виграємо танками війну
але вони нам цього допоможуть плюс як це
поставивши галочку на графітанки можемо
переходити до наступних наступна авіація
дійсно з тим що ну є корупційний
Міністерства оборони тому напевно вона
там була завжди і напевно буде ще багато
років однозначно такі історії не
сприяють утриманню зброї техніки і іншої
допомоги замороження війни однозначно
призведе рано чи пізно до нової
ескалації ми це вже проходили в 14-му
році і мені б дуже не хотілося щоб ми
повторили цю помилку
сьогодні ми поговоримо із Тарасом чмитом
військовими аналітиком засновником
українського мілітарного центру і
директором фонду повернись живим
пане Тараса Дякую що погодились на
розмову хочу почати з обговорення
поставок важкого озброєння для України
зокрема танків зараз Україна очікує на
передачу основних бойових західних
танків леопарди 2 абрамси челленджери
Можливо потім будуть і французькі
леклерки от які переваги у війні вони
можуть дати Україні і про що свідчать
готовність заходу їх надати отримання
західних саме західних нерадянських не
пострадянських танків був один з етапів
збільшення і розширення західної
допомоги для з одного боку зупинки
можливого російського наступу з іншого
боку для розгортання українського
Контрнаступ цю тему ми тиснули з весни
літа І от нарешті в кінці Минулого року
вона вже на політичному рівні плюс-мінус
Була майже дотиснута і цього року на
початку
ряд країн ви вже їх озвучили озвучив про
готовність надати західні Танки
не нові 80-х років 90-х років випуску
різна кількість різних версій різного
стані з різним таймінгом отримання тобто
якісь можуть бути отримані H через рік
якісь отримує в кінці цього року який
там Через декілька місяців але ця
історія відкриває нам дорогу до нового
типу техніки які ми раніше не отримала
саме до Танків очевидно ми не виграємо
танками війну але вони нам в цьому
допоможуть плюс як це поставивши галочку
на графітанки можемо переходити до
наступних наступна авіація про неї ми
говоримо так само довго і зараз говоримо
частіше гучніше і це вже Скажімо так
значно стратегічніший видоозброєння яке
може значно більше вплинути на хід війни
ніжки Якщо говорити про танки скільки ми
можемо отримати е-е Кулеба нещодавно
заявив що от в цьому першому пакеті чи
не пакеті це буде до 140 Танків а
скільки нам треба для того щоб не лише
поповнити свої бойові втрати а й
наростити потенціал для Контрнаступ
скільки їх не було потрібно завжди
більше на вчора і краще
140 танків - це наприклад наприклад дві
танкові бригади це 14 танкових рот
наприклад це
можливість компенсувати втрати
декількох місяців активної війни весни
наприклад з іншого боку ми отримували
декілька сотень напевно десь 400 Можливо
навіть більше
радянських чи пострадянських танків від
Польщі Чехії інших країн і будемо
продовжувати їх отримувати зараз поляки
дають
p91 глибоко модернізація т-72 їх
виробництва
тому з одного боку ми компенсовуємо
пострадянськими танками з іншого боку
відкриваємо вікно отримання західних
скільки їх може бути Ну можуть бути і
тисячі інша справа в якому проміжку часу
від яких країн в яких версіях в якому
стані
в Штатах є тисячі абрамсів Очевидно вони
нам всі не віддадуть але де
10-23 це там в перспективі в Новій 10:23
Європа може виділити декілька сотень
200-300 леопардів різних версій в
основному А4
в Британія може виділити
[музика]
100-100 плюс челенджерів других і є ще
челленджери перші в Йорданії про які
зараз піднімається питання про
можливість викупу і челенджера другий в
оманії є
леопарди перші декілька сотень в Європі
які теж зараз піднімаються як можливий
варіант для України є країни з
пострадянськими танками є Корея Якір
Греція тобто ринок до кінця не
вичерпаний і
Україна може претендувати на Сотні в
розрізі декількох років ви вже згадали
про західну авіацію от яка ймовірність
того що ми зможемо отримувати винищувачі
найближчим часом наприклад f16 або там
торнадо рафали чи гріпене найближчим
часом це він цього року 99,8%
не політичному рівні на практичному
трошечки менше відсоток напевно 70
Але я думаю що це питання буде вирішене
в найближчі місяці на політичному рівні
далі піде процес опанування
підготовки
переосмислення тактики застосування і
можливо в другій половині року ближче до
Нового року Можливо вони прямо будуть
з'явитися в Україні це не швидкий процес
На жаль хотілося б швидше але тема з
одного боку чутлива з іншого боку
складна і якщо танк Ну там як там
поламався то він зупинився А якщо вони
щось поламався то він впав і це значно
Скажімо так
небезпечніше трагічніше і репутаційно
незручно для виробників щоб їх техніка
винищують це дорога техніка це від там
40 до до 100 до 200 мільйонів доларів за
борт в комплексі
щоб отримувати погану рекламу тому всі в
тому щоб якщо його не будуть а вони
будуть То щоб вони себе чудово проявили
якісно зарекомендували і в черговий раз
показали
[музика]
перевагу
перевагу західної зброї в першу чергу
американської над радянською російською
плюс захід дозує цю передачу допомоги
Так поступово щоб не призвести там до
ескалації
є умовні червоні лінії які захід
намагається не перейти для того щоб
ну не перейти до того формату війни який
нікому не потрібен в першу чергу Україні
і незважаючи на те що ми постійно
отримуємо допомогу нам завжди критично
бракує і озброєння і боєприпасів
Розкажіть будь ласка про це детальніше
чого саме Україні постійно бракує на
полі бою всього починаючи від людей
закінчуючи боєприпасами технікою
озброєнням зв’язком оцим всім і всього
подібна війна яку ми ведемо вона не
велася в Європі часів Другої Світової в
світі
можливо з часів Кореї В'єтнаму світ не
готовий ми не готові
росіяни готова відповідно
кожного дня потрібно багато всього і
ми не можемо це закупити швидко нам не
можуть це виготовити швидко західно
можуть це передати швидко тому маємо
ситуацію коли боєприпасів не вистачає
техніки менше чим хотілося б стан її
навченість людей не такі як хотілося б
але й при цьому варіанті в не воювати у
нас немає тому як це є яке а далі по
ситуації через закінчення боєприпасів
деяка техніка просто почне відходити з
поля бою так однозначно піони будуть
відмирати гіацинти будуть відмирати
радянські танки це їх напевно остання
війна взагалі Європа зараз проводить
великі переозброєння і я думаю за роки
два максимум три так чи інакше
нас є всю свою радянську пострадянську
зброю нам і замінить її на якісь сучасні
західні відповідники а Україна коли
зможе переозброїтись на таку нову
сучасну зброю Україна - це проходить
еволюційним шляхом
щось втрачається в боях
щось ламається щось замінюється на нове
100% переозброєння я не певним що в нас
буде там найближчі якісь Можливо навіть
10 років 15 років але воно нам не
потрібно тому що ми не знаємо скільки ця
війна буде І які світ буде після неї Яка
Україна буде яка Росія буде якщо вона
буде взагалі
тому тут ну доволі складно ми еволюційно
еволюційно природним шляхом
переозброєність Як ви оцінюєте допомогу
від Німеччини і що на вашу думку з
військової техніки озброєння Німеччина
ще могла передати що могла б впливати на
а хід бойових дій
німці повільно розкачуються але виходять
на такі великі темпи і якщо подивитися
по обсягах і ти пожуто там доволі багато
всього є питання по авіації є питання по
флоту є питання по бронетехніці є
питання Ну багато по чому але
там є питання до стану їхньої армії до
готовності їхня армії і
до того що знову ж ну не одна Німеччина
не одна Америка і інші країни теж мають
підтримувати і вони це роблять і це все
ну це все так розтякається в часі і з
одного боку ніби всього всюди багато а з
іншого боку щось буде через півроку щось
буде через рік щось буде ще пізніше ну
але зараз отримаємо те що там обіцяли
літом
наступного літа отримаємо те що обіцяють
зараз і так воно природним шляхом буде
трансформуватися Чи могли би ви
перерахувати що би хотілося побачити в
наступному пакеті від Німеччини танки
бронетехніка БТР БМП важке піхотне
озброєння
прилади нічного бачення тепловізори
Ну я можу сказати авіація але навряд чи
вона буде я можу сказати щось для флоту
але навряд чи воно буде
ПВО знову
боєприпаси це актуально для всіх країн
по всіх показниках по всьому І от ми
багато тільки з чого говорили про
військову допомогу для України що ви
думаєте про корупційні скандали в
Міноборони і чи можуть вони повпливати
на допомогу від Заходу
думаю що в умовах війни треба дуже
обачно і суспільство і розслідувачам і
медіа і владі ставитися до подібних
історій і все ж таки розуміти можливі
наслідки від їх оприлюднення і мати
максимально
доведені
факти
тих чи інших зловживань і якщо вони є
все ж таки намагатися з цього не
створити шоу а
притягнути до відповідальності більш
немедійним шляхом якщо Це звісно можливо
однозначно такі історії не сприяють
отриманню зброї техніки і іншої допомоги
однозначно захід про них знає
подекуди толерує тому що Ну тому що
інакше ніяк подекуди присікає
[музика]
але треба дуже обачно тому що дуже
тонкий лід між російськими спробами
дискредитації
вищого політичного керівництва держави
вище військового керівництва держави
створення конфліктів між
силами оборони між спецслужбами в якій
вони прям хорошо Так лазять з одного
боку а з іншого боку дійсно з тим що ну
є корупція Міністерства оборони Ну
напевно вона там була завжди і напевно
буде ще багато років і я не знаю чи
якесь Міністерство оборони в інших
країнах в тому числі в США аби Німеччині
для цього немає
Звичайно є там відсотки там якісь
співвідношення і так далі І так далі І
так далі але
тут дуже тонкі люди і тут треба так щоб
ми самі собі не вистрілили в ногу
намагаючись зловити когось за 3 грн в
той час як ця дія шкодить нам на 30
тисяч давайте перейдемо до ситуації на
ремонті зараз росіяни активно наступають
на сході України і закидують наших
військових і кажуть оглянучи гарматний
м'ясо і так само все більше говорять про
можливий великий наступ росіян
найближчим часом от на вашу думку де він
може бути і наскільки може Росія
просунутися або не просунутися є
головнокомандувач які озвучив можливість
сценарій і по півночі з боку Білорусі з
боку Київщини Чернігівщини і по
Запоріжжю і по сходу Зараз ми бачимо
активне просування чи спроба просування
росіян на сході ми бачимо
спроби на Запорізькому напрямку і
можливі дії на півночі чи вдасться їм
кудись зайти чогось досягнути я покажу
тільки реально бій так би мовити якісь
прогнози тут давати буде складно Бо
ніхто не знає як піде поки на сході
активно обороняючись з великими втратами
але ми повільно дуже повільно
відступаємо в цьому нема нічого поганого
це абсолютно нормально здорова позиція і
маневру на активна оборона вона
призводить до майбутнього Контрнаступ
під Контрнаступ У нас декілька десятків
тисяч людей знаходяться в різних країнах
Європи де вчаться опановують ту техніку
про яку ми вже сьогодні згадували і іншу
з попередніх пакетів щоб ймовірно весною
коли трохи уляжиться погода спробувати
по ослаблених російських військах
вдарити на якихось напрямках прорвати
лінію це було наприклад на Харківщині і
досягнути якоїсь оперативно-тактичної а
той стратегічної Перемоги
це все фактори які залежать дуже
багатьох чинників яка ситуація зараз в
оборонно-промисловому комплексі України
чи здатна Україна виготовляти сучасну
зброю чи виготовляє її зараз і в яких
основних напрямках ну ситуація складна
бо виробництво порушено кооперація
порушена
логістика ускладнена
відключення електроенергії не сприяють
цьому
бюрократія і зарегульованість не
сприяють цьому але пока живий
не мертвий випускає ряд продукції для
збройних сил сил оборони
деяка з них доволі непогана деяка Ну яку
може загалом ця війна вона зараз мала би
відкрити багато всього нового і мала б
спонукати нас як державу до осмислення
того що ПК - це не тільки якась зброя
для власних збройних сил Це великий
продукт який можна успішно продавати за
кордон і за рахунок цього
піднімати рівень економіки які це можуть
бути сектори На мою думку бронетехніка
виробництво бтрів можливо БМП
рапів зба спеціальних броньованих
автомобілів
все що стосується безпілотної техніки
різного класу все що стосується засобів
радіоелектронної розвідки боротьби
е-е хм
Ну можливо танки але я не знаю чи ми ще
здатні їх виготовляти і чи ми не
втратили цей Потенціал є питання по
радіолокаційних засобах є питання по
двигунах є авіаційних і для бронетехніки
Уляна Україна в останній роки і
виготовляє зараз якусь техніку яку
хочуть купувати за на заході з лютого
продаж за кордон заборонений в нас і це
одна з проблем розвитку АПК насправді бо
держава і семени купує в достатній
кількості бо немає ресурсу і
забороняє продавати з одного боку з
іншого боку Ну я вже озвучував
тініші в яких ми були Ну в яких в нас
щось купували тобто ті ж безпілотники
наші невеликих кількостях але контракти
були от як раз це про безпілотник якщо
хочеться поговорити і про безпілотні
комплекси які успіхи зараз України в
аеророзвідці і виготовлені безпілотних
комплексів безпілотників ситуація
складна через те що ми протилежні від
закордонних комплектуючих через
бюрократизованість регульованість
обмеженість з боку держави це ускладнює
вільне постачання комплектуючих навіть
там по часу це там плюс два місяці плюс
мінус
Це ускладнює серійне виробництво випуску
плюс Ми створюємо величезний попит зараз
або нам треба багато Ми купуємо багато
ми втрачаємо багато і світ намагається
зараз збільшувати об'єми виробництва в
себе тих чи інших складових там двигунів
чи електроніки для того щоб задовольняти
наш попит ну відповідно ціни росту
відповідно продукції росте плюс війна
змінюється і там безпілотник який був
актуальним в 14-му році чи в 15-му вже
не актуальний так само то який буде
актуальні зараз там через 10 років буде
неактуальний це постійні вже живий
процес тому ті виробництва які які живі
вони і підтримують всі вироби
намагаючись заходити в якийсь сусідніші
умовно кажучи там з безпілотника
бригадного рівня почати робити ще там
корпусного або з корпусного спуститися
на Бригадний рівень а з бригадного на
батальйону
ми всіляко вітаємо і захочуємо здорову
конкуренцію намагаємося купувати
якщо продукція відповідної якості
потрібна війскам в різних виробників
таким чином щоб підтримувати різних
гравців так чи інакше і давати
можливість ринку
саморегулюватися і жити лелека фурія
Shark як вони можуть конкурувати
західним це якраз одна ніша бригадних
комплексів
можуть конкурувати ціною можуть
конкурувати реальною обкаткою війною
можуть конкурувати в Україні 24 на 7
сервісом супортом з точки зору
покращення конструкції програмного
продукту з точки зору
перенесення оцьої кнопочки на пульті
сюди або там оцьої іконки сюди так щоб
оператором було більш комфортніше і
загалом система була більш така
вилазаніша
заходом тут складніше ну якщо це
американський безпілотник Ну пишіть
листа в штата і може вам через рік щось
змінити тобто тут є багато дуже
практичних компонентів навіть навчання
яке організовано в Україні і не потребує
перекладачів це вже там багато плюсів до
до рівня опанування і чи захочуть їх на
заході теж собі купувати Як ви думаєте Я
думаю
нам Є з ким конкурувати однозначно на
перелічені вами моделі були до 24 лютого
експортні контракти
які На жаль через вторгнення
повномасштабне призупиненні але я
сподіваюсь що ця війна дозволить
обкатати вироби розгорнути виробництво
частини з якого вже перенесена в Європу
і
так би мовити створити українському ПК
новий потужний кластер якого там не було
після розпаду Радянського Союзу ось це
ще поговорити про роботу фонду за
останній рік як вона змінилася у
порівнянні з іншими роками до
повномасштабної війни
Як у всіх в країні змінилася все всюди і
дуже швидко і масштабно
фонд
Як і всі ми не був в повній мірі готові
до вторгнення але
з перших днів буквально з 25 лютого
активно включився в забезпеченні сили
оборони в першу чергу на північному
напрямку тому що задача стояла втримати
столицю бо поки стоїть Київ Стоїть
Україна
а далі масштабування величезні проекти
Суми кількості всього для всіх по всьому
і зараз на початок нового року фонд це
близько 100 посад близько 80 людей
близько
300-200-300 мільйонів гривень в місяць
[музика]
десятки різних напрямків від поточних
закупівель потреб для фронту тут і зараз
до середньострокових проектів які ми
побачимо влітку а то навіть і осінь
повний живим є першим благодійний фондом
Який отримав ліцензію на закупівлю та
імпорт товарів подвійного і військового
призначення і от які проекти ви вже
втілили що закупили і який є в планах
зараз в розробці найгучніший наш це
закупівля турецького комплексу байрактар
тб-2 в складі трьох літаків наземної
станції боєприпасів необхідно комплекту
зіпів комплектуючих для головного
управління розвідки Міністерства Оборони
11 бронемашин для 36-ї бригади морської
піхоти СБУ
Загалом у нас було десь біля 10-15
задівської закупівель там був військовий
зв'язок там були і тепловізори при
одинічного бачення військового стандарту
там був зв'язок як ну зв'язок інший там
подвійного призначення теж
це з того що було минулого року зараз ми
в нас є декілька проектів по зброї
найпублічніший з них це так звані довгі
руки терору закупівля 186 мм 120 мм для
кожної з 31 бригад територіальної
оборони
у нас
є в роботі ще декілька проектів по
важкому піхотному озброєнню по
бронемашинах теж великі кількості по
модернізації системи протиповітряної
оборони це напрямок у нас працює з 2017
року
Ну і в цьому Ми шукаємо цікаві кейси по
ринку з того що могло би дати
Максимальний кпаде в цій війні
хочеться запитати ви можете на ринку
зброї так розумію купити все і не ще не
коштує теоретично так якщо є кошти І от
як обираєте те що закуповувати за
принципом
Ну тут складніше питання Те що треба для
війни подекуди абсолютно незрозуміло
людям для війни там можливо з того що ми
робимо найбільше потрібні комп'ютери
монітори і радіостанції але люди
ведуться на от на Щось таке медійне
гарне і і і байрактар тому тут потрібно
якісно розділяти між тим що треба і тим
що хочуть люди хочуть суспільство
у нас це плюс-мінус виходить з одного
боку з іншого боку є Ну от зараз ця
війна Вона вимагає колективної зброї
треба важкі кулемети 12,7 мм треба
міномети
60-82 120 треба
40-міліметрові гранатомети треба зпузу
от це те що потрібно тут і зараз для
тієї війни яка відбувається в бахматі в
солдарі і в цілому на сході саме важка
колективна зброя от мені шукаємо
намагаємося контактувати закуповувати
запускати спільні проекти з партнерами
це все не швидко ви не можете прийти в
магазин і купити там 50 мм подекуди це
півроку переговорів узгодження юридичних
норм схеми закупівлі
це все строго регулюється в Україні в
Євросоюзі в окремих країнах це все дуже
складні процеси вони не швидкі тому ми
намагаємося виходити в паблік і
комунікувати коли у нас є умовно тверда
угода підписана і ми точно знаємо що ми
здатні це закупити і після проплати ми
або отримуємо або запускається
виробництво або там якась інша схема
запускається ця війна на руки
Я не знаю я не буду питати у вас
прогнози але запитаю за яких умов
Україна отримає повну перемогу у
остаточно А за яких умов ситуація може
повторитися за кілька років
замороження війни однозначно призведе
рано чи пізно до нової складці ми це вже
проходили 14-му році і
мені б дуже не хотілося щоб ми повторили
цю помилку
є дуже маленький шанс що звичайно ми б
могли її в майбутню так звану третю не
програти але знаючи наше суспільство і
бачачи там попередні роки з 14-го ми не
дуже готувались до цієї війни
всіма президентами урядами верховними
радами міністрами і так далі
тому навряд чи щось зміниться з одного
боку з іншого боку
що таке перемога для нас ну Напевно це
повернення на кордоні 91-го року Напевно
це вирішення проблеми Придністров'я
Напевно це
роззброєння в якійсь мірі позбавлення
ядерного статусу Російської Федерації
можливо розділ цієї країни на окремі
компоненти окремі складові незалежні
одна від одної і
і створення
достатньо потужних збройних сил село
ворони яких буде достатньо для того щоб
жодна з інших країн ніколи в майбутньому
не наважилась повторити те що нас
відбулося Дякую вам за розмову пантерес
дякую